[Music]
question party is very simple
a bunch of viewers tweeted questions at
me and tarik and we're going to answer
some of them right now
you edited i'm ready okay scott hardy
asked
who are your comedy idols ooh
that's a great question my comedy idol
is tarik
now tarek you answer oh my god your mom
is hilarious
my comedy idol is amber ruffin that's
how you make a show i don't know who is
it
uh i mean whoopi goldberg whoopi
goldberg absolutely
i mean idols are strong like hearing you
talk about jumping jack flash like
jumping jack flash was the beginning
like
i'm mad that so for me it's eddie murphy
yeah i'm mad that
whoopi and eddie didn't do a jumping
jack flash meets like axel foley oh
solve mysteries that would have been
great it would have been great
loved it loved it love them thank you
scott hardy all bye seth
is there any place in new york that you
always wanted to visit but never had the
opportunity to go
great question look i don't like to go
places
i'm so sorry i've been i think i can say
i've been all around the world
and i did not want to see any of it
being around the world and don't
see any of it great it's really great
just some people are traveling people
some people are sightseers i am not they
would you describe yourself as a
homebody
that's right or a party boy i only want
to be at a party or in my house
that's it wow yeah i have lived in new
york for a while
and i've pre i've been everywhere in new
york i've like taught in
all five boroughs but the one place i
haven't been inside
this is the fire station that they shot
the original ghostbusters in
i just want to slide down that pole
where where is that
that is in tribeca oh
i'm pretty sure that's in tribeca i want
to go look at it yeah let's go look at
it never because i'm never leaving here
great unless they throw a party then
i'll be there yep
x hatch rearrange the whole game with my
rooker sound
x asked what are your favorite things
about your new writer
oh my god okay so earlier in this show
you saw corinne she's a brand new baby
and i didn't know she existed yeah i did
we
and you just say [ __ ] i'm sorry
we used to do baby once candy together
she's a delight
so talented so funny of course she did
baby wants candy yeah baby wants candy
as a musical
improv group um that everyone knows at
one point or another yes
uh i did baby once candy i went with
baby once candy to china
whoa buddy let me talk to you for a
while
yeah this is the freaking best i got to
ask you about that um
again i was on the great wall of china
talking about
[Laughter]
it truly was is there a party going on
no no i'm going home
it looks like it looks on your computer
it's the same thing
if you saw it you've been there it's the
same anyway
[Laughter]
so karina's great i'm glad she lives
here in new york
patrick um i've loved him for years he's
also a second city baby
he is in la
patrick does all of the like he did tong
song
he does a lot of um uh um
parody songs yeah and i was like i'm not
doing no parody songs
he also gets patrick like our age stuff
like
yes i like patrick because like patrick
gets
where we're coming from yes patrick and
i are a certain
age and that's i almost said 35 like a
joke
and you old if 35 is your joke age
oh father they're just very talented and
i'm lucky to have them
the best let's do this again soon
[Music]
[Applause]
you